okay let's uh start up the public
hearing for the special command
childcare um we'll do the Pledge of
Allegiance really quickly I'll I'll take
I've never let it all I'll take the lead
I guess um I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
okay okay all right so uh let's get to
where we are so
we were in executive session we had um a
executive session on House Bill 1056
representative walner introduced a
non-gain Amendment um the executive
session was recessed and we are now on
the publicly noticed uh hearing on the
non- derain amendment 202
24-7
60h um so representative wner do you
want to introduce the non- gerain
amendment since you're the sponsor of it
real quick
um and then we will conduct the public
hearing on the non-gain
amendment members of the committee Mary
Jane walner um State Rep from conquered
member of this committee um um
so a few weeks ago or maybe it's longer
than that um I learned that when they
were looking at when the childcare ADI
um providers and the department were
reviewing um the rules because they're
in they're working on rewriting them at
this point they came across something
that um I think maybe a lot of the
childcare providers might not have been
aware of I'm sure the department the
departmentment was but in law child care
is limited to 13 hours per day except in
emergencies um and in recent recent
years the work schedules of families has
drastically changed um I think we all
know particularly in the medical field
people are working more three day days
on 12 hours a day um a lot of a lot of
families are finding themselves working
in um longer shifts and um needing child
care for many more hours each day um I
was at our County commit I was at our
County meeting and the um person who
runs the Department of Corrections
talked about how he has because they are
so short staffed they now have have
every one of their Corrections Officers
working at least one day a week two
eight hour shifts back to
back so that's a 16-hour work
day right and then they need an hour
probably to drop the child off and pick
the child up so if one of those
Corrections Officers did need child care
there is a real issue here and I think
we're seeing this more and more in um
the child care world so um I just took
the law and struck out the 13
hours and after I did that the
department let me know that that the
problem with that is it could throw
Child Care into needing to um be in um
compliance with
residential with res residential um
rules and that is something I don't
think that any of us want um so because
it would be there would be no limit on
the amount of time so after some
discussion with um Melissa clemet um
yesterday we did work out some addition
some different wording so on the
non-gain amendment I have an amendment
um so is that confusing
enough but I do think I think what
Melissa and the legal department at the
department came up with actually will
work better and I guess we could bring
that up at the exec session would that
be the way to do that or do you want to
see it now I assume well let's do it now
U because we're in a stance of public
hearing um so I always remind people
that the rules exist and we can do what
we need to do unless someone objects um
so unless somebody's
goinging the amendment to the amendment
uh we will do that hearing no objection
we will do that okay um so so we just
have to hope none of our 400 other
colleagues object but that's fine
there's a there's a whole bunch of them
like they look like
this printed on
my cut and paste real cut and paste okay
so the
difference so the difference between
the amendment I just hand we just handed
around and um the amendment that the
non- derain amendment is that in the
last if you go to that last
sentence instead of just striking out
the 13 hours we leave in the 13 hours
except in emergencies we leave that in
or situations when the parents or
Guardians are working over 13 hours
during a 24hour period or parents or
Guardians are that are deployed by the
military so I think the military one is
one that the department has been hearing
about um families needing longer Child
Care during those times so so this is
the amendment to the
amendment I'm open to questions are
there questions on the amendment to the
amendment um
okay hearing none thank you
representative oh I'm sorry repres I
apologize I didn't see you takes me a
second to decide if I actually want to
ask a question um are there issues with
defining like do the parents have to
provide um proof that they're working
over 13 hours like every time or is
this I'm not sure how to freeze I think
that would be a good I think that would
be an excellent question to ask the
department
this this wording did come from the
Department uh we talked about we talked
about another alternative but then came
came back to this one and I think that
that would be a good question for them
to talk about how they would monitor
that um or what what
obligation um a provider would have to
provide information about children who
are there longer so
um yes representative Paige so I'm
I'm obviously supportive of the goal
here I think the the one question I have
you know the concern about the original
version of the amendment was about
pushing it into sort of this residential
category of care right
and with the military deployment
piece the the lawyers who discuss this
with you they're not concerned about
that with the military deployment piece
I I think that the bet that also I think
is a better question for the Department
Department because they're the ones that
have experienced this request I assume
um over time and I don't know how long
these deployments are are they for six
months or are we talking about over the
weekend which is what came to my
mind uh further
questions um my only question so you
haven't sent this off to OS yet I have
not sent it off to OS I would think it
would go off as a committee Amendment if
that's what we decide to do oh I imagine
it would
um I imagine it would I'm just trying to
think about timing um because I'd love
to get this um done today so um all
right let's uh let's move on to the next
unless there's further
questions um next up representative
grassie thank you Mr chairman
representative Chuck grassy straford 8
for the record um I I thank you for
getting this before the committee uh
this was something that my wife
mentioned to me after a meeting that she
had with the childcare advisory Council
and that this was an issue and it's
something that I've been familiar
with can only work with licensed child
care facilities and they're looking at
providing services for many single
parents who have weekend Duty or the one
week Duty uh in the summertime and and
uh even some longer term things but they
can only deal with licensed Child Care
Facilities um years ago when we had an
unlicensed child care facility at my
house we took uh my wife took care of a
lot of um children for nurses at the
local hospital and it was many a day
that we would get a call that says that
so and so called and sick and I have to
stay or you know it's going to be a long
surgery this afternoon I can't get out
um and uh we sometimes kept a child
overnight uh but these were parents who
had unusual circumstances sometimes you
didn't know until the last minute but
being a family childcare you can do that
kind of stuff um when this came up that
you can only have for 13 hours we both
shook our heads and say what the heck's
going on here and and why and it's
unfortunate that the department just
can't change their rules because I
understand they're in the process of
fixing their rules right now to get this
done and they could put it into rules so
we wouldn't have to maybe deal with this
again in the future if we see that what
we're doing today isn't the correct
thing to do um that's why I thought the
original amendment was good but the
proposed amendment is fine um and you
know they may have to work their rules
around that but I think it's something
that we can uh that we should encourage
um and again uh you know the National
Guard is looking at Contracting with
childcare agencies to provide services
for their
soldiers and this is something that
makes it hard for them to
do questions from the
committee none thank you representative
grassy than last pink card is Melissa
Clement from Department of Health and
Human
Services
good morning chairman Barry and members
of the committee my name is Melissa
Clement and I am the chief of the
childcare licensing unit I'm here to
answer any questions I've heard some so
I'll start there and then we can
continue the conversation so when this
was brought to our attention we were
looking at the fact that if a child is
in care for longer than 24 hours then
that's a residential care it's not just
child care which was why we wanted to
not eliminate the number of hours of
child could be in care but we also
recognize that there are times when a
child may need to do so we we thought
just by striking the 13 hours um would
be problematic so we said you know we
have the 13 hours accept an emergencies
so you have those times when parents
didn't know they were going to have to
work a second shift they called the
program hey can I can the child stay
longer because I was just asked to stay
longer at my position so that's an
emergency situation but we also
recognize that there are times now as um
represent Senator wner brought up that
parents are being scheduled for shifts
that are longer than the 12-hour shifts
so we wanted to make sure we have
Provisions for that as well we have also
heard from um others about the military
Provisions when we were considering this
we were thinking of weekend deployments
we weren't thinking of a week or six
months so um looking at that we're a
little concerned because that's also
going to bump you in a residential care
if a child is in something longer so
we're trying to strike that balance um
my
recommendation and Dorian shley the
manager um is here also and maybe she
can speak to this but we were just
confirming back there maybe having um
changing the wording so that it says or
parents or
Guardians um who are deployed during
weekend deployments um we were thinking
that's maybe a you know to specify that
it's not someone who's deployed for 6
months a year that that a child is being
placed in a Child Care Program 24 hours
a day and also um programs have to be
licensed as um in addition to their
child daycare there's a night
care license that they would have to um
be approved for and that would include
approval through the fire department
locals for to operate those type of
hours this statute itself talks about
the number of hours each child can be
and the reason we didn't want to strike
13 is that we believe as an agency it
makes sense for to have some limit on
the number of hours a child individual
child could be in care not necessarily
the number of hours that a program can
operate a program can operate up to 24
hours if they're licensed appropriately
but each child has to be there for only
a certain number of hours and not there
hours and any additional
questions yeah I was I'm sorry I was I'm
trying to bring up the rules for night
care while you were talking about night
care like yes trying to remember what
section it was I don't have operate
nightcare so I'm not as familiar with it
um yeah and under the statute RSA
1702 um those are the definitions of
child care programs and there's a night
Care Agency definition in statute as
well in the stat what's the RSA again
I'm sorry RSA 170 e colon 2 okay um
under the definitions
okay so just are there sorry are the
questions from the committee while I
frantically read these rules yes uh
president Phil thank you for coming um I
don't know if he wants water right now
sorry just um I actually agree with your
Amendment to the amendment to the
amendment about um not to trimming it
down to weekend appointments National
Guard I just think the committee should
consider that because I I definitely
think that that's an arrangement where
you get a family member or friend to
take your child if you are a single
parent deploying um that I totally agree
with you so I just wanted to kind of
make a comment more than a question I
guess um thank you thank you uh further
questions from the
committee um seeing none it just so it
looks like the rules for night care are
about evening hour operations 7 p.m. to
5 a.m. yeah so sleeping Arrangements
those type of things what needs to be
provided overnight yeah so if they were
provided
so putting this together in my head
because I didn't think I should have
thought about night care for this it was
my fault um I didn't I knew you had to
have a special thing for night care I
just my brain didn't go hey look good
into that um so if this goes into place
children placed under this care it's
emergency or military they would need a
night care license yes if it yep okay
um so I'm I'm wondering if it would just
make uh let me read the I haven't read
the RSA you said it was RSA 760e if you
want to sit down it's just going to take
me a second I in hrsa
170 in case you guys think good question
yeah ask question how was your weekend
um of course yeah of course um I uh
experienced this with an employee who
was a National Guards member two young
kids during Co actually and she had
Regan deployments and she struggled very
much to find someone and obviously it
ended up being a
unlicensed um neighbor daycare situation
who could take her children you know
very early in the morning like 5:00 a.m.
and you wouldn't see them again until
the end of the weekend so um I I I'm
actually delighted to hear that National
Guard is looking for people to provide
the childcare because I think our
National Guards people have families and
this is a huge issue these weekend
deployments so um anything we can do to
make that easier I think the committee
should definitely prioritize so okay all
right I am now informed um okay so RSA
170e which is just general definitions
just defines night care agency and ACC
agency means a
family to 40 then goes to define the
hour so the RSA makes this kind of broad
definition and the rules tighten that
definition up to a actually defines
evening hours as 7 to five um so I guess
I guess my since we're going have to
send this off to ol us anyways I guess
would it make sense to make it more just
in line with everything because like
here we're defining number of hours and
then night care agents is being defined
by set hours not a total number but a
set 7 p.m. to 5 a.m. um so I'm wondering
if that would just make since we're
already going to be tinkering with this
and I didn't in my brain I was like I
don't want to conquer this up but I feel
like we might conquer this up um would
it make more sense
to to just to to I I guess what would be
the arguments just like having it all
line up well I was going to ask what it
makes sense to kind of go back to the
original language and instead of
Striking 13 completely just change 13 to
24 to bring it in line
with that it wouldn't go into
residential care or sorry yeah sure so
the difference between the night care
agency that is the license type that a
program is operated under and those are
the hours that they operate under this
statute talks about how many hours an
individual child can be in care versus
the amount of hours that a program is
operating so I want to make sure we that
distinction is clear but because take
taking the night Care Agency hours and
plopping it here wouldn't solve the
problem or solve the conversation about
how many hours a child can be in care
versus when a program can operate you
you explain that excellently thank you
okay now that makes sense in my head
thank you so much okay all right so yes
that that makes way more sense to do it
like this um and uh and any other
questions from the committee we're going
to be have a weird awkward recess till
11 but
uh what yeah we need the adment anyways
okay um so I guess the agent what is the
agency stance do you want the amendment
to the amendment or do you want the
amendment what's the agency
stance the amendment to the amendment
would be preferable I think it gives the
greatest flexibility for any emergency
that CS pops up plus the additional
protections or additional ability for
families that are working longer and
have those military deployments for a
weekend is what I would recommend unless
it's strong objections okay um all right
any other questions and I just learned
about night agencies all right um thank
you that's it uh all right the committee
is I guess we're done with the public
hearing I don't have any other pink card
signed up uh do we have a blue sheet I
don't see anything on the blue sheet I
don't do they put uh do do I don't see
anything written on it I don't think so
so the blue sheets empty um NH I don't
think that this is an online submission
thing but we'll take a
look I think I'm like the only chair
that reads the online submissions um no
who else does
it oh they verbalize it okay read I read
them I'm I'm a nerd I'm I'm a nerd uh
let's see if they have a non derain I
just don't even know if they have a non-
derain
section um I don't see it I don't see a
non-main section um so I don't know so
anyway for the for the bill there was
eight people that support and two
opposed it I I don't know if that's for
the amendment or for the under actual
original bill um with that we'll close
the public hearing for 1056 and um I
believe representative walner you'll
work to get this over OLS on a rush um
so we can take care of
it yeah just and I'll work on committee
reports while I sit here um all right
I'll see you guys at
11:
e
oh wow if they did a better job of
drafting the non- gerain non-gain
amendment that they could never seen
coming okay we're going to open up for
executive session for the house special
committee on Child Care um we're waiting
on
1056 didn't we already do 1657 we did
already do so we don't need to do
1657 I think why are
weting uh because she has the amend
amendment to
it that was the non-main amendment the
whole purpose of this
morning it's
okay okay
um was
1409 did I just do
14 okay yeah this one we can start
working on okay so let's open up the
executive session on House Bill 1409
relative to to review by The Advisory
Council on child
care I'm going to read this again
relative to review by the advis by The
Advisory Council on child care of child
care center licensing violations I
believe this bill was recessed we were
in an itl
disposition um and DHHS said that they
were going to get a draft rule proposal
to us uh which they did so I know that
we are in executive session but without
objection I would like to bring dhh up
to present uh what they have worked on
um which would obviously supplant the
need for this bill they did send it to
us last night so if you guys want to
come up and show us what you
have that would be
excellent thank you chairman Barry and
members of the committee um for the
record I'm Melissa Clement I'm the chief
of the childcare licensing unit um so
what I um sent last night to um the
chairman and members of the committee
was a draft proposal of the rule that we
would add to our childcare licensing
rules we are currently revising those
rules with the childcare advisory
Council and other members of the Child
Care community so there is there will be
an additional section for what we are
calling an independent informal dispute
resolution that process would start
after doing an informal dispute
resolution um which is the dispute
resolution brought to the department
then if the provider wishes after that
dispute resolution they could further um
ask for another independent dispute with
the childcare advisory Council in a
panel that was developed between the
childcare advisory Council child care
licensing that panel would include a
member of the childcare advisory Council
the members would be made up of child
care providers that are licensed and
have you know are in good standing so we
would choose ask for volunteers choose
among them have um a process where three
to five people would be chosen out of a
pool that we would have and um this
whole policy and procedure was developed
using a federal procedure for certified
Medicaid providers through our um Bureau
our Licensing Bureau for healthare
facilities um CMS they also have this
process so we use that as our model um
essentially we're asking for a panel of
peers to review the decisions that we
made with the um what the provider is
disputing and then that decision will be
brought from the panel to the department
for review that was sorry a very quick
summary does anyone have any questions
on it are there
questions um yeah I have some thank you
for answering my question last night
that was very nice it was late too um so
I just want to kind of like walk through
what this would I understand this is the
draft I understand that there's probably
still working that's still working like
so I accept all of that and I accept all
that this is being done in good faith so
I just want to walk kind of through the
process like so there's a finding by a
licenser the center provider probably
provider is a better Term Provider can
then appeal it then goes to the
IDR right yes and the IDR upholds or
overturn return Returns the finding MH
assuming the finding is upheld then the
provider can then appeal to the
iidr um and that I
iidr is a panel of three to five
providers uh would that just be a
standing pool would that be a standing
like three to five different what we're
envisioning now because we know not
everyone's going to be available and
there's time frames for needing to
respond so we want to get a pool of
maybe 10 12 15 something like that
depending on the response we get and
then once an request comes in we would
do our best to match the provider who is
doing the dispute with the people who
are on the panel that have programs like
there so it's a family child care
provider if it's a school age provider
we'll do our best to find someone on the
panel who will match those um so that is
the process one point of clarification
and I understand it's semantics but we
live and die by our um wording these are
not appeals because appeals have an
official appeals process through DHHS
and that is for our enforcement actions
against licenses this is why we call it
an informal dispute because it is not an
appeal process okay it's like it's an
independent
review it's informal review not it is
different it's not the same but it is
similar yes got it um that's totally
fine um because I do there is a Bonafide
appeals process yes correct okay so um
they don't appeal but they request a um
dispute dispute review well that's the
proper term right um so they they
request a dispute review so that leads
from my understanding from reading what
was sent um that leads to two possible
outcomes um but let's go over what that
dispute review would look like so um
they can only consider evidence that was
presented at the time of the visit is
that
correct that um I'm looking at just
we're on the same page I'm on on the
proposed rule that you sent I'm on uh
J
okay so um that the evidence presented
existed at the time of the visit so it
has to be evidence that should have been
available maybe for some reason our
reviewer didn't see it so but had to
have existed at the time the citation
was found as opposed
to documents being created after the
fact okay to demonstrate compliance but
they were not available at the time the
finding was made yeah so an example of
this would be like um if you came
looking for a signed copy of the
expulsion policy right and you didn't
have it and then magically it appeared
you know two weeks later postdated right
and it's magically all worse so like we
wouldn't be able to consider that
because they didn't have it right on
them at the time um okay so they would
okay so that that that makes sense right
you can't just re you can't just
introduce you're not escalating a
dispute process
um determin determine whether there is a
Prepon of evidence the citation did or
did not
occur determine why the evidence
presented creates a change material
facts okay so two and three no issue
there um so from there there's two
outcomes they say yes this finding was
accurate or no the iidr believes this
finding was inaccurate so obviously if
they find it it was in is accurate
that's the end of that we move on um if
they let's talk about what happens if
the iidr says no uh the Department's
gotten this wrong now twice right
because it's the licenser was wrong and
the IDR was wrong y um so now what
happens let's walk into the process what
happens next sure so what we're
proposing is that um the iidr decision
comes back to us and then as a
department we're also reviewing it to
make sure that the decision that was
made met that criteria okay and then
from there if we agree that it meets
that criteria we would remove the
finding okay if we don't feel it meets
that criteria we would write our
decision we would put that in writing we
would send our decision with the panel's
decision to the program so that is full
transparency as to what occurred and
that remains in the file okay so that so
there's so now there's this the
department disagrees with the
iidr it goes in so what what can happen
with that information now because this
isn't an appeals process right there is
a formal appeals process so can the can
that finding of the iidr be used in the
formal appeals process could I as a
provider go in and say well the iidr
actually disagreed with the department
they agreed with me like or is that is
it just done so these are the things
that that could happen with that at that
point there's not a further appeals
process there could be in the future if
say say the program um I'm trying to
think um didn't complete whatever the
finding was if we choose in the future
to maybe it's a repeat citation we find
them non-complying again or there's
other um citations further down the road
we could choose we could find the
program we could take it to an
enforcable action and then at that point
we because we're relying on information
from this disputed finding yeah if
that's the case once they get to that
appeals process they can appeal it there
it would be up to the aaou to yeah and
they could but they could introduce this
as a they they could use this in their
effectively they could use this in their
in their defense absolutely and the
other piece to that too in addition to
our process so say we don't um remove
the citation they program also has the
ability to um give us a written
statement that we post with their
corrective action so they could choose
to further bring this um to the public
by saying we went through this process
this is why we don't think we should
have been cited that is something that
they're able to do in a written
statement they have to provide a
corrective action plan to show that they
fixed it but they're also able in our
rules now currently to have and in the
statute they're able to have a written
statement that's posted online with
their information I also want to um
bring forth that out of the idrs that we
completed in
2023 um there were we only had eight of
them but out of those there was only out
of those eight there's only one that
remained as cited so as a department we
do regularly either remove the citations
we did that three times we um mix we had
a mix of removing citation or revising
evidence because there are times when we
have several pieces of evidence it may
be that there's 's a piece of evidence
that we remove but the overall citation
might still remain or we may just revise
evidence only and we did that one time
so we do I I want to say we do often
remove change when these things come to
us so it's not yeah just so you have
that understanding as well yeah okay um
are there further
questions the committee yes RS and wmer
yeah I I don't have a question I just
have a comment I think this is a really
big step forward for for child here to
have this and to include providers who
actually do this work I think it's
really really good and I'm sure as time
goes by you'll you'll probably be back
to Tinker with it a little bit but yes
um thank you very much for doing this
work and thanks to providers who worked
on it yeah no I really appreciate the
work of the childcare advisory council
with us on this and the providers so
thank you appre thank you chair thanks
for taking my question um is there any
uh remuneration or or anything like that
for the providers who are going to serve
on this panel or is it just a straight
volunteer it's a straight volunteer as
it's presented right
now um any other further questions about
this policy on this bill um I'm G to I
want to Echo what representative walner
said um I do think this is a big step
forward um I do think this accomplishes
the goal of the bill um which was to
bring
a sense of fair I'm not and I'm not
accusing the department of being unfair
but bringing a sense of fairness to that
process um so personally I believe that
this will suffice for what I was looking
for from the industry standpoints I
think the CC talk advisor Comm you guys
agree I take it um okay so that I I I
think I know and I accept that this is
still being work and it's being done I'm
going to take on good faith that it's
being done um so I thank you and I think
it's a Well already very well thought
out um so you're it's not even that
you're close I think you're almost
done thank you very much okay any other
questions before we go okay thank you so
much okay thank you okay so with that we
are on an itl disposition on
um 14 House Bill
1409 um I believe I made that motion I
see no reason to withdraw that motion um
is there any objection any other
comments on the bill the motion of
inexpedient to legislated on House Bill
1409 second I think it had a second but
if you want to fire it off you can do
it um because we were on discussion on
the bill so we had to have had a second
um sure uh anyway so if the clerk's
ready the clerk can call the
role all right um chairman Barry shair
votes
yes um representative
Phillips representative ball
representative Nelson yes representative
walner yes representative cran votes yes
uh representative Howard yes
representative O'Neal yes representative
Paige yes all right vote of nine to zero
okay with that uh the motion of any spe
to legisl house B 1409 path carries on a
vote of 9 to Z is there any objection to
that bill being placed on the consent
calendar hearing none household 1409
will be placed in the ex
on the consent calendar is inexpedient
to
legislate um I assume we still haven't
heard back on
1056 you want to go grab it real
fast anyone want to volunteer to do the
report I can take care I'm already I'm
already writing every I'm already
writing election law half of election
law reports fire off a this one won't
nearly be as long as the one that I just
did this one be like 1405
yeah handled by
rules
um okay and we've done 1567 I don't know
why that was Ren
noticed
um I probably was supposed to do the
report for 1567 and
didn't so which leaves us with just two
more bills
um I don't believe we've been let me see
if we've been sent anything while we're
waiting for representative
walner let me see if we've been sent
anything from our friends in the Senate
I don't believe we
have of Howard gets to watch me in
election law where it's
like that's between having 41 bills and
having
six yeah we don't do any yeah well I was
telling yesterday I was like it's a
totally different world there where it's
like it you know it's going to be a 101
vote it's like you know want talk no all
right call the vote no yes move
on the the the committee the committee
reports are always hilarious for those
because it's like and the and the
majority of the Committees believed was
like there was no discussion like how
did you have any any inclination was
happening um no nothing from the Senate
so yeah that'll be the end of it today
will probably be our last day unless
they sent us something from the Senate
um I'm sorry you don't enjoy this I I I
this is actually I've told election law
this is actually my this is actually my
favorite committee
um yeah it's it's well like here it's
like you know we we do things like we
actually get things done there's stuff
gets accomplished election law is just
like it's like it's just you know get
there at 9: do this until noon go eat
lunch come back at one o'clock go back
to doing this go back to doing
this it's a different uh it's a
different world I think we're only going
to have one contentious vote will be the
last one we do um which not bad for a
whole two years of work only have one
contentious
vote really oh was that that was
probably a jumbled up vote well there
was
some
was it so at four so it is a it's four
now I'll be interested to see the roll
call on that one it's always I I I
always love those issues that
don't
yeah I I I always like those issues that
just cut across party lines like that's
one of those weird ones right um those I
always find those things to be so
fascinating um another one of those is
like cannabis legalization cuts across
party lines it's a weird one um um you
there's no uh man is this going to be
200 or is this going to be
196 all right represent of wner do you
have your Amendment so the amendment to
the amendment
um
yeah it's like uh I take all these phone
calls in my Cher Center this I'm right
outside the infant room so there's a lot
of crying in the background and people
are like you need a go like I don't even
I it's not it's like it's it's like it's
like white noise I don't even hear it um
you know I could tell the difference
between the like I want attention cry
and the like I'm in danger cry and
that's they do sound differently um okay
all right so we're going to open up the
executive session on how Bill 1056 uh
representative walner we were on the
amendment um representative walner had
moved
2024-the um and then you can introduce
the new Amendment to the amendment great
I will uh withdraw the first am the non-
terain amendment okay and we can move to
the next Amendment all right so you're
so representative wner is moving 202
24-9
58 uh to House Bill 1056 I will second
the motion um we did just do the non
derain hearing on that so when the clerk
and the speaker see this we just did the
non gerain hearing on this um is there
discussion on the
amendment yes representative Nelson
thank you Mr Mr chairman I I don't have
a copy of that Amendment oh it's
okay you didn't want to read it right
whatever does everybody have copies of
the which is
one no this is
995 want you have more copies in
995 shouldn't give to the
committee it it
yeah okay I just think there
wer okay and there's a stack of them
here's here's the actual so so the the
the 995 is different than the one we
heard today it is substantially similar
but it is um the same subject in the
same RSA so it's definitely yeah
yeah it is a little different um okay so
we're now on discussion of amendment
2024-25 6 is a discussion on the
amendment uh repr Warner I I think the
amendment reads just the way we uh
discussed it Y and um do would allow
children whose parents work more than 13
hours to be in a Child Care Program and
allow for children to be in a a Child
Care Program if their parents were
deployed during the weekend by the
military okay um yes representative
Phillips my only um question is um when
it says by the weekend some of these um
weekend deployments are three days does
that matter it's a long
weekend um so I'm just throwing it out
there because I just happen to have an
employee who had to go through all yeah
it's a very it's a technical question so
um I I had the same thought and I didn't
want to send it like back again um so I
think well you had the thought before me
so you should have brought it up yeah I
know I know um I did um I what what my
game plan was on this was to use the
legislative intent mechanism um and just
State what our intent is with it um and
that should suffice because a weekend is
not defined anywhere a weekend can be
three days you can take a long weekend
um so I was going to say that and I'm
glad you actually brought that up
because I was going to say two things is
I was going to say uh I am voting for
this amendment is my intention is voting
on this amendment is that it includes
long weekends for military deployments
the other thing I was going to say is is
uh my intention in voting on this is it
includes all definitions of the military
so the dod and the um National Guard New
Hampshire National Guard if you are
doing military things all of them all
the branches the Navy the MC all of them
I'm voting this with the intention that
they are all included in there and I'm
assuming that that's going to go in the
notes which means when it if it never
goes to court they'll look at that and
say what the legislative intent was so
we'll hopefully the courts read what
representative creation writes down um
but yes I had the same
thought any other further um comments
questions concerns on the amendment okay
with that the clerk will call the role
on the amendment um and then we'll have
a new disposition
all right chair Barry the chair votes
yes representative Phillips yes
representative Paul yes representative
Nelson yes representative wner yes
representative cran votes yes
representative Heath uh yes
representative O'Neal yes representative
paig yes right n to zero okay with that
uh committee the amendment is adopted
2024 to0 995h uh representative walner
is recognized for a new
motion
I move that we have ought to pass with
Amendment
0995 representative W was to pass an
amendment on House Bill 1056 as amended
by 20240 9 995h I will second that
motion is there any discussion on the
bill as
amended hearing none the clerk call the
rooll um all right representative Barry
chair votes yes sorry uh representative
Phillips yes representative ball
representative Nelson yes representative
walner yes representative crean votes
yes representative Howard yes
representative O'Neal yes representative
Peach
yes okay with that uh this bill reported
out as ought to pass as amended any
objection to it being on the consent
calendar hearing none Ron W can you
handle the report for this one since you
did all of the leg
work I'll get the report to you yeah
okay um yeah if we could do it I know
you're busy but if we could do it I'd
love to be get this on the not this
Thursday but next um okay so with that
we're going to come to our last bill
which I think will I don't know but I
think will be our only Bill where we
likely take a divided vote um so before
we do that I want to say thank you if we
don't meet again I want to say thank you
to this committee I believe we' actually
done some really like awesome things for
the industry as a whole um we may meet
again uh so this may not the the goodbye
speech but it could be the goodbye
speech um so I was just saying uh while
we were in break uh I've really enjoyed
the deposition of this versus my other
committee where we do this um it's been
a pleasure working with everyone and I
do think we have produced some excellent
work product that I do believe will
impact uh the child care system in New
Hampshire um so with those lovely
uniting Works say I believe we're going
to take our one divided vote
um and and there's a reason why I helped
held it to last um so I will open up the
executive session on House Bill
1584 um uh since I'm down a number we'll
just skip to the part where
Representative walner makes a
motion I'll move
inexpedient representative walner moves
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second I'll second repres page second
um as I
said to speak to your motion
I'm sorry this is the bill that would um
increase the number of uh children that
a provider could have before they would
need licensed um right now you can have
three children U plus your own children
um in order to not need a license your
license exempt at that point this moves
it up to four children that are
unrelated um my feeling is that we do
have an obligation to be sure that kids
are in Safe Care um the more we erode
these um ratios and these um licenses
the more likely we're going to have
incidents the fire marshal did send us
some stuff I was sort of sorry that they
aren't here um to kind of talk about the
safety of children children this
and this bill actually I think does
bring forth a safety concern for
especially the youngest kids it's very
hard to imagine you're in a second floor
apartment and you're going to get four
very very young children out of that
apartment safely if there was a fire so
or if there was some emergency so that's
the reason the other the other other
reason I've been thinking about is we do
provide some
safeguards particularly around the um
police checks and the security checks
that we do on all child care providers
and that means this is a group of people
caring for children where there'll be no
no um records checks to be sure that
they don't um provide a threat to
children so um I think that's a concern
we're just increasing the number of
children who are in places that don't
have these
safeguards further comments from the
committee on the bill um okay I'll I'll
give my I I respect what the member said
I actually agree with a lot of the
points um the principles of it are not
misguided or misb at all um you have to
juxtapose that with the the issue of you
look at the members who are on this bill
they are mostly members from rural
communities these are the areas that
have the hardest time finding access to
child care and it is a it is it's like
with a lot of things right you're OB
you're obviously you're always balancing
safety and quality against access and
affordability these two things are
often in direct conflict with each other
so the question is is where do you where
do you fall right no one on this
committee wants
safe non quality child care no one on
this committee wants child care to be
inaccessible or inable we all hold those
two positions and this is the one bill
where you kind of see where that
dividing line is as where do you end up
falling um neither side is wrong um
they're both rights to their own merits
I am choosing access and affordability
in this instance um because I don't
believe that the compromises to safety
and quality which would exist um
outweigh the current lack of access and
affordability um I hold the
socialization not the social I I told a
joke on the radio day not the socialism
isation of the child but the
socialization of the child um at a very
high regard um in the development of a
child and I know that parents who can't
afford or find accessible Child Care
their child not only is it a financial
strain on the New Hampshire economy by
that person not reentering the workforce
but it's also a detriment to that child
because that child loses those
socialization skills um and the other
thing is is like while this is an
unlicensed Arena um children do tend to
be in a safer environment um when
they're around perennial caregivers um
so I respect everything the member says
I want to thank the member for all the
great work I believe we've done um and I
don't I don't want this bill to leave us
in a bad a bad disposition we're still
friends I think um we just we just
happen to have this this is the one
where the dividing line um Drew Drew um
which is why I intentionally kept did
towards the very end so I'll be voting
against the motion of inexpedient to
legislate that's my that's my reasoning
um and we'll let the we'll let the house
floor decide where this one goes yes
representative CR thank you um I will
just say I would not be opposed
necessarily to increasing to four if
there were also Provisions for you know
the the ages of of the children um or or
something like that but I guess that
gets to licensing um I just feel like a
blanket increase to to for is not
something that I can vote for y fair
enough represent
paig thank you and I I think I'm the
only person on committee representing a
pretty rural area of the state and I
will say that I really wanted to support
this bill um and I'm sad that our
committee work is coming to an end
because we have so much more to do um
and I think you know my response as
someone from a rural area who
experiences these things is we need to
continue to do more
to
facilitate um the creation of more
family and group Family Care and so I
think that there are there are ways we
could have our cake and eat it to on
this and so what I'd hope is that
however this comes out we keep working
with each other on this issue because it
is an important one um and we've been
working so well together so uh looking
ahead to next year anyone who wants to
work with me on on family and group
Family Care I'd love to do that and I I
totally agree with all that the family
and group care in our when we did our
our listening sessions that was to me
the obvious solution for those rural
communities right because they don't
they don't have the populations to
support larger centers um so the the
family group CARE is the obvious and I'm
very proud We got that new license type
introduced um that's that I believe is
going to do a lot of good as well um so
I I appreciate that and I I recognize
that that's like I said this was this
was a tough one where it was like yeah
you going to pick a side on this one and
it just kind of is what it is and that's
okay um yes represent wner I do want to
say that I do think that that it'll be
interesting to see if the zoning uh law
that we are passing I think that may go
a long way in helping providers um
increase the number of family childcare
providers and communities I I I
completely agree and I said I think
we've done what to see what this what
our friends on the other side of the
wall do to our hard work um but um I I I
do genuinely believe you know it's not
often in conquer you can go home and be
like I did something good today um I
genuinely believe the work that this
committee has done did some good and we
did some good today even though we're
going to disagree on this one um all
right so with that the uh clerk will
call the role on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1584 right chairman Barry chair votes
no representative Phillips no
representative ball no representative
Nelson no
representative
walner yes representative cran votes yes
representative Howard yes representative
O'Neal yes and representative paig yes
shockingly five to
four and with that the motion of in
expedience carry Motion in expedience
legisl on house 1584 carries on a vote
of 5 to four those will not be on the
consent calendar uh representative wner
will do the dueling reports I take it um
and um and thank you all and I said if
we don't meet again thank you it's been
a pleasure um I do hope we meet again
but if we don't thank you it's been a
pleasure that concludes our committee
business as of now see you guys want to
see you
guys